Community Pride on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Silver State Schools Credit Union is
setting the bar high this giving Tuesday
I sat down with president and CEO Scott
a Arcos to find out how
it is giving Tuesday and no one gives
more to this community and their
customers than Silver State Schools
Credit Union and we have the president
and CEO of Silver State Schools Credit
Union with us today Scott a Arcos it is
so great to talk to you and let's talk
about some of the ways that you guys are
giving to everyone with the high cost of
college tuition these days students they
really need a hand and your credit union
you have been providing scholarships to
students for decades tell us a little
bit about that we have and I'm glad you
asked about that so Silver City Schools
Credit Union is proud to award annual
scholarships to outstanding Nevada High
School seniors there are people over
profit foundation so Silver State
Schools Credit Union has awarded over a
million dollars in scholarships since
the program began and like you said
that's been for decades and and one of
the questions we often get asked is what
criteria are you looking for and so the
pop Foundation is looking for high
school seniors who to demonstrate
excellence in academics but more
importantly also how they serve and how
they're good stewards and the local
community and and that's through
extracurricular activities and Community
involvement so uh Silver State Schools
Credit Union will announce our 2023
application process and application
deadlines early next year and we
encourage eligible High School seniors
to actually apply for one of the ten two
thousand dollar scholarships this spring
there's actually something else that you
do that is a great Community initiative
it's the Happy Times Calendar contest
what is that students submit a piece of
artwork that reflects what makes them
happy and that's why we call it happy
times and uh it really we're saying
because this is probably one of our
members favorite uh things they come in
and ask for these calendars and so uh uh
the student winners get a cash reward
and their original artwork is actually
framed to commemorate uh their reward
and uh and then we also award the
student's school at Cash Warren and
supported the art program so we want to
continue that program as well so uh each
year about this time we acknowledge
these students at an award celebration
and that's going to be on uh December
5th this year and uh and that's when we
distribute the calendars uh to our
members as well so for the new year and
so it's a great event as I mentioned and
another thing that the credit union is
doing to give back here on this giving
Tuesday they had a school supply drive
and a food drive already this year and
now there's another Drive in progress
what is that and who does that benefit
so server State Schools Credit Union is
currently accepting new and unwrapped
toys for less fortunate children this
holiday season uh all four of these
drives benefit students at our focused
schools uh which are Rex Bell and
Stanford Elementary Schools as well as
the girls empowerment Middle School also
known as gems uh so anyone can help make
the holidays brighter for these students
and their families by donating toys at
any one of our tent branches throughout
the Las Vegas Valley now through
December 10th
thank you again to Silver State Schools
Credit Union for sponsoring this segment
now let's